[Musique]
le topless les paillettes les plus le
Moulin Rouge sont chauffés rit c'est
elle qui tourne jour et nuit ses revues
qui ont jalonné l'histoire tantôt désuet
tantôt kitsch mais si glamour cet
univers nostalgique qui nous laisse tous
rêveur
[Musique]
chanson vous allez l'adorer elle va vous
envoûter vous entêtez vous exaltez
[Musique]
900 spectateurs une bouteille de
champagne à chaque table entourée de
colonnes Maurice d'affiches de Toulouse
au traite c'est le défilé de haute
couture mais pas seulement ce sont des
gambettes en l'air un tourbillon
floutant dont personne n'aurait pu
imaginer un vrai succès un choc visuel
le temple de la femme créée par des
hommes mais habiter animés sublimé par
des créatures des déesses belles ou non
histoire que nous allons vous raconter
ces cris au féminin et dans la des
mesures de Dieu
[Musique]
il y avait tout ce monde qui gravité
autour de Montmartre et qui faisait que
Montmartre était les centres du monde
parce que Paris était déjà les centres
du monde à ces années dans ces années-là
et Montmartre était les centres de Paris
1889 c'est aussi l'année de l'Exposition
Universelle l'année de toutes les folies
de la démesure la Tour Eiffel la
félicité la garde or c'est le pont
Alexandre III Le Petit Palais le Grand
Palais le métropolitain et même le
trottoir roulant alors quoi depuis
naturel que l'inauguration du Moulin
Rouge une salle consacrée à la fête mais
surtout à la femme ziedler et hollower
ont d'ailleurs dans un premier temps
voulu baptisez ce lieu le temple de la
femme mais le dessinateur de la maquette
Adolf Villette caricaturiste et
traditionnaliste offre pour une
référence au quartier réceptacle des
Moulins de Paris ce sera un moulin et de
surcroît il sera rouge rien n'est trop
cher le jardin sera grand et la salle de
Bâle la plus audacieuse de l'époque
les artistes dansent avec le public sans
barrière une première le public de la
soirée de la première soirée aussi des
autres soirées c'était des grands
bourgeois et des aristo qui voulaient un
peu un canailler il y avait des
danseuses il y avait des blanchisseuses
il y avait les gens de monstre et donc
tout ce monde-là s'est réuni sous le
chapiteau du Moulin Rouge embrassé tous
les classes sociales et tous les niveaux
de tous les âges une fois le Moulin
Rouge est rigide il manque un petit
détail le choix des artistes et des
attractions pour les attractions il y a
d'abord l'éléphant conçu pour
l'exposition universelle aux leurres
l'achète avenue Rapp et le rapporte dans
le jardin du moulin et ce qui est
amusant c'est que à l'intérieur de cet
éléphant il y avait une danseuse du
ventre et alors il fallait payer un
petit supplément pour pouvoir voir cette
danseuse il paraît qu'elle a dansé dans
une pâte de l'éléphant pour les artistes
leur choix s'arrête sur une blonde
Boulogne bien vulgaire un type lugubre
maigre et des articuler et sur leur
partenaire brune à la dentition assez
espacée tous sont déjà des danseurs
stars de l'Elysée Montmartre
[Musique]
4 a dansé le quadrille à l'époque ils
sont 80 aujourd'hui sur scène
72 girls et vin Doris dancers on les
appelle les Doris girls du nom de la
maîtresse de ballet Doris embauché dans
les années 60 celle qui a été la grande
danseuse et chorégraphe des revues les
plus connues du monde au début des
danseuses des cas puis 8 12 et enfin 60
rejointe très vite par les danseurs sur
scène la nuit en répétition le jour
[Musique]
on était là à 12h30 pour l'échauffement
13h début de répétition jusqu'à 16h30
17h 19h30 on va être de retour pour les
deux spectacles on a un rythme de vie
qui est quand même assez soutenu on
travaille de spectacle par soir 6 jours
sur 7 et on a en plus de ça des
répétitions plus quand ça s'impose des
répétitions entre les deux spectacles
dans la salle de répétition quand les
répétitions effectivement sont très très
dures il faut déjà apprendre les
chorégraphies
et en plus de ça il faut tout de suite
mettre sa personnalité et puis la touche
américaine le chorégraphe des Jackson
Five de Diana Ross et de Stevie Wonder
big Woodson
[Musique]
la directrice artistique du Moulin Rouge
après avoir dansé au Moulin Rouge en
1980 de danseuse elle en est devenue la
maîtresse de ballet en 1997 elle cadre
et encadre la troupe de jeunes danseurs
et c'est elle qui les choisis le casting
est sévère
les meilleurs danseuses
il faut aussi que les filles sont très
grands
elle est quand et en physique qui va
aimer en valeur les costumes alors
malheureusement il y en a pas assez dans
une pays il faut vraiment chercher
partout dans le monde pour avoir les
meilleurs plus en voulant les mères
il faut avoir le must du must il faut
lancer des auditions attirer les jeunes
filles en folie aux quatre coins du
monde tout doit faire 1m75 minimum et au
final peu de françaises mais il y a bien
une raison à cela pour arriver à niveau
pour ici il faut quand même
et pendant les vacances on va à l'école
de danse encore plus on a installé en
Angleterre on finit l'école 3h30 là il y
a le temps d'aller à l'école de danse
après on donne deux trois heures et on
reste encore le temps pour faire les
devoirs c'est pas facile
mais c'est possible chapeau aux filles
françaises parce que arrivé à le niveau
nécessaire ici je devais être très très
fort et là en installer par exemple il y
en a des centaines et des centaines
[Musique]
et parmi ces australiennes il y a
Kourtney le coup de cœur de notre
cadreur elle fait bien partie de ses
petites filles qui commencent très tôt
la danse fraîchement arrivée elle se
rappelle de ses débuts difficiles elle a
intégré le balai très jeune innocente
petite fleur fragile et précieuses elle
s'est vite senti perdu
[Musique]
notre française Mathilde elle est là
depuis 7 ans elle est parfaitement rodée
au spectacle et en est même devenu une
des ambassadrices elle a commencé la
danse sur le tard après des études
supérieures je pensais que la danse au
niveau professionnel était inaccessible
pour moi je n'ai d'une petite ville de
province comme mon professeur de danse
va emmené voir le moulin j'étais là wow
c'était un rêve quelque chose vraiment
d'inaccessible je me suis dit si un jour
je dois être danseuse ce sera au Moulin
Rouge et ce sera pas ailleurs du coup
j'ai passé l'audition et par chance
vraiment par chance j'ai été prise et
depuis 7 ans maintenant je vis vraiment
un rêve ce sont des athlètes des Formule
1 de la danse et en déambulant dans le
Moulin Rouge on découvre les reines de
la souplesse dans les pubis dans tous
les recoins allongez les jambes en l'air
la tête par terre avant pendant après le
spectacle les corps des danseuses ne
font jamais de pause bassin gambettes
grand écart en perpétuellement et les
danseurs sont tout aussi énergiques
dynamiques frénétique Michael a un corps
de rêve abdo biceps et le 1m85
obligatoire chez des garçons pas d'un
père pas d'excès médusel aucun indice
pour imaginer qu'il a déjà 41 ans on
sait qu'on est en train de tenir comment
faire attention et aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui non on ne fait pas ça on est
des on est très professionnels on vit
que pour notre métier on fait attention
comme tout le monde sait est-ce qu'on
mange on fait attention à ne pas faire
la fête trop parce qu'il faut travailler
tous les jours et alors tous ces idées
sont décidés de passer et ça fait qu'à
long terme on est en carrière plus
longue funky d'être danseuse mais c'est
vous qui l'avez voulu joli môme et les
corps il faut les habiller les parés
c'est le travail des habilleur un métier
propre aux cabaret ils sont 23 au Moulin
Rouge
[Musique]
les petites mains sont discrètes on a du
mal à les entendre
c'est surtout important pour les
artistes parce que ils ont pas penser à
ça quoi c'est pas le problème eux ils
doivent donner le meilleur de même sur
scène et pas se créer des costumes mais
nous nous sommes là pour que ça se passe
bien en police c'est beau corps énoncé
sélectionné sur entraîné à la beauté
sculpturale on est loin des codes du
début du siècle où les filles étaient
rondelles petites éclectiques tout est
mesure élégance raffinement
[Musique]
rue Notre-Dame de Lorette à quelques
rues du Moulin Rouge l'atelier de
broderie de Caroline Valentin se trouve
au fond d'une cour c'est un des cinq
ateliers d'art appartenant dorénavant au
Moulin Rouge l'institution du cabaret
est devenue le défenseur du patrimoine
de la France
prisé depuis des siècles la broderie à
l'aiguille et au crochet n'a jamais pris
une ride l'atelier de Valentin débute
son histoire avec la du Lido bonheur
puis l'opératine de Paris l'Académie
française le cirque sans oublier
évidemment le Moulin Rouge et ses mini
costumes si Caroline Valentin a brodé la
robe de Vanessa Paradis dans la fille
sur le pont de Patrice Leconte elle
prend autant de plaisir à sacler au
costume du numberger Moulin Rouge tous
les costumes sont entièrement refaits
pour qu'ils aient toujours l'air neuf
comme alors début il y a 20 ans le
costume girl lui n'avait jamais été
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc on a on a redéfini un petit peu
voyez la ligne de
bonnet est absolument du décolleté est
absolument magnifique ça aussi c'est
très beau c'est c'est comme si les seins
étaient offert dans une petite corbeille
les contrastes avec le noir très fort et
là par exemple le fait que ce soit
entièrement brodé je veux dire il y a
pas un millimètre carré qui ne soit pas
brodé et y compris avec des toutes
petites rocailles voilà ces petites
perles là on appelle ça de la rocaille
c'est entièrement brodé voilà c'est un
hallux inouï
le costume est lancé avec soin par
Caroline Valentin comme un bijou bon eh
ben mesdames mesdames à tout à l'heure
elle part rejoindre les moulins et
l'atelier de création de mine Bergès
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au troisième étage du Moulin Rouge mine
latente elle est la mémoire du moulin du
haut de ses 83 ans derrière ses lunettes
noires elle a habillé deux trois jeunes
filles
Joséphine Baker tous ces jours je les ai
habillé
[Musique]
mais ça doit être très très solide parce
que ça dure ça joue deux fois par jour
c'est pas mal des années je crois
qu'elle arrive qu'on est bonjour
bonjour
alors on va essayer on va regarder la
taille je pense que ça doit être ça tu
me dis Moulin Rouge c'est vraiment un
ensemble il y a le chapeau les bottes le
string le costume voilà les gants
éventuellement c'est c'est vraiment un
ensemble très complet de choses qui
définissent une silhouette dans chaque
tableau avec leur caractéristiques
spécifiques
[Musique]
voilà voilà
elle est prête
ça c'est un de mes costumes préférés je
trouve qu'il est très très joli il est
musical mais il tricouture pour moi
vraiment j'adore ce costume je veux pas
Caroline j'adore il est plein de
spiritualité
[Musique]
pour l'essayage ils ont choisi la plus
belle notre petite Courtney qui elle ne
fait qu'un mètre 71 et qui se sent tout
d'un coup poussé des ailes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
super très contente
[Musique]
complètement mais en même temps
c'est nickel on dirait
[Musique]
c'est pas le look du moulin
dans l'atelier de mine Vergès quand un
costume sembler réussi on fait appel aux
couturières pour validation est-ce que
je peux demander à l'atelier qui
viennent te voir
dites venez voir Daphné venez voir test
de la tenue de hamburger réussi
[Musique]
des costumes du Moulin Rouge à l'inverse
l'iconique l'emblématique l'un des
modables robes cancan c'est plus de 200
mètres de foufou sur son jupon une jupe
qui pèse en moyenne 5 écoute la
bagadelle de 5000 euros
le cancan c'est des foufous mais aussi
des bottines
[Musique]
Olga à 32 ans elle est la soliste cancan
la grande acrobate du Moulin Rouge
depuis 12 ans venue de l'Est si solaire
au rire franc la danse est rentrée dans
ma vie assez particulière c'est ma maman
qui m'a inscrit en gym quand j'étais
toute petite elle m'a dit tu vas être
champion du monde de gym et en fait ça
n'a pas passé comme prévu ma maman mais
je pense au mieux parce que finalement
aujourd'hui
j'habite à Paris je travaille à Moulin
Rouge donc c'est vrai que la danse a
changé complètement ma vie en fait au
cirque je faisais les pyramides humains
et jeter la porteuse
je trouve et oui parce qu'en fait j'ai
toujours été grande et j'ai dû arrêter
le Gym parce que j'étais très grande
donc j'ai vraiment quand j'ai arrêté le
Gym je pensais que ma carrière ne
n'arrivera jamais au bout de quelque
chose ça a changé beaucoup de choses le
Kazakhstan est loin maintenant je pense
qu'à l'époque je n'aurais pas pu
imaginer d'être ici aujourd'hui elle a
rendez-vous pour essayer ses nouvelles
bottines de cancan
rue Fontaine à deux pas du Moulin Rouge
parce que le Moulin Rouge travaille dans
le quartier dans tout le quartier la
maison clairvoy et le petit maison
derrière cette porte se trouve l'atelier
où les petites mains travaillent le cuir
c'est là où toutes les chaussures du
spectacle sont conçues et entretenues la
maison clairvoy a elle aussi des
rachetée par le Moulin Rouge pour
sauvegarder ses mexicains
on travaille pour le moulin mais aussi
pour tous les cabarets le Lido le Crazy
la nouvelle Ève pour le cinéma le cirque
le théâtre plusieurs corps de métiers
qui sont réunis au sein de en fait du
terme Beautier on est formé picker à
prêteur celui qui fait le dessus de la
chaussure monteur finisseur ce qu'on
appelle le travail de pied c'est lui qui
va faire l'assemblage du dessus et du
dessous de la chaussure en incorporant
tous les renforts à l'intérieur et puis
on a ensuite le bichonneur et le
réparateur qui va s'assurer de
l'entretien et de la qualité de la
livraison aussi la paire de chaussures
sur le trottoir d'en face la boutique
Salomé bottines French Cancan bottes
cuissardes siglamour si sensuel si
gourmande toujours au féminin devrait
chaussures de sport ce sont elles qui
entre le cordolga dans le sol la Seine
la terre ferme ça c'est des éléments en
fait où il faut absolument que l'artiste
soit bien maintenu soit bien tenu et la
bottine de cancan pour nous c'est la
chaussure la plus technique et la plus
et la plus sportive
bonjour bonjour Olga
merci d'être
venues
que tu souhaites à chaque fois notamment
un petit peu plus large bien robuste
aussi et ben voilà il y a plus qu'à les
essayer pour voir si tout va bien après
restera juste un petit coup de
bichonnage à faire avant que tu puisses
les récupérer directement au moulin
c'est chouette tu m'as mis la semelle
comme d'habitude elle est trop bien
utiliser ici un petit peu de place pour
quand le muscle va gonfler tu arrives à
bien bouger avec
non c'est bien malgré les chaussures et
c'est quand même c'est le talent et tout
ça c'est pas évident pour l'acrobatie
mais vraiment je me sens comme dans les
chaussons j'ai l'impression d'être
vraiment bien faut pas se faire mal et
même quand on tombe en grande écart que
vous voyez qu'on tombe on s'éclate par
terre on peut dire ça comme ça tout est
protégé de deux côtés en fait on sent
pas de leur dans les pieds ils sont
absolument en bon forme merci je les
récupère et du coup tu les auras en loge
directement ce soir comme d'habitude
avant d'aller s'écraser en grand écart
sur la scène elle aime passer de l'autre
côté de l'Image et se cacher derrière
son boîtier photo elle fait des
shootings de mode avec ses copines du
Moulin Rouge la carrière de danseuse est
courte il faut penser à la suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'une seconde
[Musique]
à la nuit tombée Olga range son appareil
photo et se glisse dans le Moulin Rouge
par l'entrée des artistes
[Musique]
elle pointe le gardien c'est une
obligation pour tous les danseurs
[Musique]
elle se dirige ensuite vers sa loge qui
est situé dans les étages une loge
pourrait uniquement en hauteur comme si
elle disposait d'une petite tour
d'ivoire elle a ce privilège car elle
est solide cancan mais aussi danseuse de
serpents on place singulière le
spectacle enfin prête maquiller et en
franche-comtante de la tête aux pieds
Olga s'apprête à entrer sur scène c'est
le moment le plus agréable le plus
intense
[Musique]
la scène s'enflamme est dans ce sont le
diable au corps et le plus petit que
suite
[Musique]
prêt pour le solo cancan c'est 45
secondes d'adrénaline qui retiennent le
souffle des danseurs et les spectateurs
ah non pas encore vous manquez de
background cancan
à l'origine le Campan était un moyen
d'expression subversif en 200 ans que
s'est-il passé en 1820 à Paris au milieu
du très codifié quadri en vogue dans les
balles parisiens une minute
d'improvisation exécutée par les hommes
uniquement le cavalier seul et quand les
danseurs brisent l'ordre de la
chorégraphie ce n'est pas pour rivaliser
de grâce mais au contraire pour faire
assaut de mouvement débridé sous
anarchique et hurlements strident c'est
la séquence du chahut ou du cancan quand
quelques audacieuses elles aussi essayer
aux cavaliers seuls les autorités
réagissent violemment contre cette
remise en cause des normes sociales
surveillance arrestation et condamnation
systématique
ces parisiennes rebellent et insolentes
agitent leur jupons comme le drapeau de
leur émancipation une émancipation qui
passe par l'indépendance financière pour
des centaines de milliers de filles du
peuple en 1890 à Paris une ouvrière
gagne au maximum deux francs pour une
journée de 10 heures de travail et voici
que Moulin Rouge des étoiles nommées
rayon d'or la Goulue gris dégoût mon
fromage à sauterelle gêne avril gagne
300 400 500 francs par jour pour les
blanchisseuses la danse professionnelle
est une formidable opportunité de gagner
leur indépendance et pour la première
fois et danseuse gagne plus que les
danseurs
alors dans une feinte de délire canae la
bacante du ruisseau brusquement trousser
jusqu'au ventre offre en pâture au
Cercle vide qui s'est resserré sur elle
l'apparition de ses rondeurs c'est ainsi
qu'un écrivain de la fin du 19e siècle
décrit l'apparition d'une célèbre
campaneuse au nom évocateur la Goulue la
Goulue née Louise Weber a grandi à
Clichy en banlieue parisienne lavandière
comme sa mère modèle à ses heures
perdues elle danse en repassant
excentrique avec un tout-pet d'enfer
elle n'est pas jolie elle a de la
gouaille et son nom de scène trouve de
nombreuses origines il y a des légendes
qui disent qu'elle était la Goulue parce
que elle buvait la fin de vers et donc
c'était la Goulue parce que elle adore
les boire ou sinon la Goulue parce que
il adorait la vie ou le c'est joli mais
c'est pas vrai elle était un certain
moment la maîtresse d'un monsieur qui
s'appelait goulu donc là voulu sur le
galop infernal d'Offenbach il est
danseuse ont souvent leur jupons suggère
l'expression du désir féminin alors
qu'il est encore de bon ton de simuler
la retenue innocence elles osent inventé
et nommé des pas qui respirent la
sexualité et ça rejet ainsi une
prérogative masculine aujourd'hui bien
sûr avec le recul
du temps elle était une prothémisme ou
même une des grandes figures du
féminisme aujourd'hui oublier Olga
ressemble à ces filles du peuple qui en
veulent c'est pionnières d'une société
envoie d'émancipation ces guerrières
et elle était complètement on peut dire
fofolle elle elle était
collée elle dansait elle donnait à fond
en fait c'est la liberté c'est c'est
l'incarnation de la femme forte je pense
que je vous retrouve bientôt je pense
c'est un personnage que que j'aime bien
incarner parce que ça aussi ça va très
bien avec ma personnalité que je n'aime
pas rester sur place je suis un petit
peu folle aussi donc ça colle bien au
début du 20e e siècle le cancan devient
une attraction touristique on est loin
des revendications féministes mieux
encore le cancan s'exporte c'est alors
que l'anglais Charles Morton le père du
music-hall lui ajoute la dimension
French pour suggérer le petit quelque
chose attribué aux Françaises ces
françaises audacieuses et qui font rêver
alors que le cancan monte sur scène
devenu star il s'agit et se codifient
allez vous êtes mûres voici les 45
secondes d'aulgar les plus acrobatiques
des touches
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à quelques encablures de Montmartre
Montreuil on se demande ce qu'on fait là
on s'est engage cela ne Jonathan
s'entraîne deux fois par semaine ils ont
30 ans son sœur est frère et surprise
ils excellent en patin à roulettes les
rollers à quatre roues des années 70
avec des bottines assez bien serrées
encore une fois pas trop de secrets pour
arriver à leur niveau ils ont commencé
tôt très tôt
à trois ans ils sont sur des patins lui
est champion de France de hockey elle
championne de France de patinage
artistique
mais là ils ne glisse pas sur la glace
mais sur une minuscule en bois de 2
mètres 10 de diamètre
[Musique]
ok ils effectuent leur numéro depuis 6
ans au Moulin Rouge dans leur famille
c'est 5 générations dans le cirque
Bouglione à Monte-Carlo c'est son
arrière-grand-père qui ouvre la danse
avec son numéro de roue de la mort si
dangereux qui n'en meurt sur la piste
leur grand-père invente un autre concept
soit disant plus stable le roller sur
table
font des réglages pour leur numéro du
soir un numéro de voltige de patinage
artistique plus que de roller aériens et
risqué une minute sur scène à 300% avec
la tête qui va à gauche à droite en haut
en bas on est quand même à 45 km/h
suspendu au coup de son frère c'est elle
qui impulse la vitesse si elle ne
s'arrête pas à son signal les chances de
la redresser diminuent la force demandée
pour la remettre sur patin et colossal
peut changer la direction la rotation la
position du corps c'est pas si évident
si je fais une grosse chute et qu'on
sorte de la table
on est vraiment c'est pas c'est pas une
blague c'est pas une façon de le dire
c'est la vérité
c'est vrai que c'est pas c'est pas
facile
[Musique]
un entraînement très physique autant
pour les acrobates que pour les danseurs
Mathilde notre danseuse française se
rend 4 fois par semaine au backlin Club
une prestigieuse salle de boxe dans le
10e arrondissement de Paris
[Musique]
et elle ne fait pas les choses à moitié
elle se bat comme un homme c'est une
guerrière comme notre soliste de franche
cancan Olga
[Musique]
place Blanche des 19 heures
la blessure c'est vraiment le point noir
de notre métier si vous vous tordez la
cheville vous pouvez plus travailler
du bas du dos et tu vois tellement
crever avec le japonais
en coulisse les artistes se préparent
leur salle d'entraînement se trouve dans
les états du moulin le réchauffement est
vital pour éviter les accidents restez
constant c'est très difficile on a eu
deux grosses chutes dans notre carrière
c'est arrivé au Moulin Rouge coup sur
coup quasiment on a beaucoup appris de
ce jour-là parce que dès qu'on a la peur
de te faire mal la peur de tomber ça
nous amène à travailler différemment et
à tomber plus
on était tombé une fois c'était une
petite chute mais on a eu du mal à s'en
remettre moi j'ai la tête qui a touché
le sol et là sur sur une semaine en
nature tomber trois quatre cinq fois
jusqu'à se faire très mal parce qu'à la
fin à la fin on jouait de casser les
ligaments croisés et soso c'est ouvert
la lèvre il y a eu des points de suture
donc voilà c'est c'est vraiment une
partie aussi
dans la tête
[Musique]
de l'autre côté de la scène le bal de la
salle celui des invités ils sont
accueillis placés chouchoutés par la
plus grande brigade de France
700 sauts à champagne sont déposés sur
les tables chaque soir le Moulin Rouge
et le plus grand consommateur de
champagne au monde le spectacle commence
[Musique]
sur scène comme dans les coulisses le
défilé des plus belles jambes du monde
et permanent
au deuxième tableau l'orientale notre
acrobate Olga entre en scène si elle
s'est envoyé ces gens dans l'air elle
est aussi capable de le plonger dans
l'eau et dans ce numéro de la piscine
elle prend des risques tout réside dans
ses muscles l'aquarium se dresse au
milieu de la salle et les pitons de 5
mètres et de 60 kg surgissent et porter
les maintenir pour éviter d'être étouffé
oui le numéro de la piscine assez
exceptionnelle dans le spectacle je
trouve que si je le faisais pas ce
numéro c'est quelque chose qui m'aurait
impressionné
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je commence à connaître très bien les
serpents pour ne pas me faire étouffer
donc j'ai un peu l'habitude comment
comment ça se passe ils sont nourris
avant le spectacle ils arrivent
d'extérieur je pense qu'ils ont d'autres
choses à penser que metteurs dans la
piscine je l'espère en tout cas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans les coulisses c'est au tour des
fraises sur Pilates le stress monte la
tension est palpable
il suffit qu'il y ait un peu d'eau il
suffit qu'il y a un peu de poussière
celui qui a un petit détail qui est le
niveau enfin que la table soit pas très
droite il y a plein de détails qui font
que qu'on peut on peut tomber
[Musique]
je sais pas mais
tu sauras chanson
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
suivante la difficulté monte d'un cran
ils ont choisi de couper la musique pour
entendre le bruit des rollers et
l'accélération de leur corps en
mouvement
sur cette figure ils se mettent à nu on
entend leur souffle il ne se cache plus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'amour d'un frère qui porte sa sœur à
bout de bras triomphe
[Musique]
l'amour au Moulin Rouge fait rêver on se
demande toujours si les danseurs tombent
amoureux entre eux à la scène comme à la
vie c'est le cas de notre australienne
Courtney qui est tombé amoureuse de Léo
dans sa ruse depuis 15 ans au Moulin
Rouge mauvais garçon il est aussi acteur
au cinéma à ses heures perdues ces deux
tourtereaux ne se quittent plus ils sont
même devenus les égériques l'amour du
Moulin Rouge et des histoires d'amour
Moulin Rouge il y en a toujours eu la
plus forte la plus polémique celle qui a
fait scandale au début du siècle c'est
l'amour entre deux femmes entre Colette
écrivain mais aussi artiste musical et
sa maîtresse la marquise de Morning pour
débuter l'année 1907 Moulin Rouge
programme rêve d’égypte à la fin de la
pièce elles échangent un fougueux baiser
quel esclandre et ça a été un énorme
scandale parce que déjà deux femmes qui
s'embrassent sur scène c'était beaucoup
mais qui en plus elles étaient
maîtresses dans la vie était trop les
gens ont commencé à lancer de gustaï ou
de tomates mais c'est terminé
véritable pugilat c'était un acte
féministe un acte lesbien un acte de
revendication de d'une sexualité libre
et autre le scandale ne dure que de jour
notre grande dame leur vol la vedette en
1908 il y a eu un autre moment très fort
la valse à loupé a été dansé et créé par
Max et airly c'était un très bel homme
et il a dansé cette valse chaloupée avec
une toute jeune une femme qui commençait
à être connue qui était mistinguette
mistinguette on la retrouve quelques
années plus tard lorsque le Moulin Rouge
ouvre à nouveau ses portes au début des
années 20 il ferme en effet après le
terrible incendie de 1915 qui éclate
dans le vestiaire des danseuses et
détruit la salle principale et le
promenoir c'est mistinguette qui fait
revivre un âge d'or au Moulin Rouge
c'est la naissance des grandes revues
celles qui vont façonner l'histoire de
cette institution tout au long du 20e
siècle et qui font encore aujourd'hui la
recette de son succès mistinguette c'est
avant tout une collectionneuse d'hommes
max d'Orly Earl Leslie
Maurice Chevalier elle était pas jeune
elle était pas fraîche mais elle avait
une force elle avait un charme fou elle
avait une verve une gouaille une façon
de d'être qui était unique mistinguette
c'est aussi la première grande star
plusieurs plumes ont chanté ses plumes
de Colette à Montréal il célèbre celle
qui nomme impératrice aux esquisses
j'emmenus ou encore monument national
mistinguette était une femme
géniale elle était le manager
d'elle-même elle avait inventé le
personnage mistinguette génial mes
orgueilleuses égoïste prétentieuse c'est
elle qui ose dire je chante je danse je
vais pleurer je suis acrobate je joue la
comédie on peut dire que je suis
universel il n'y a pas d'autre femme qui
fasse ce que je fais pour aller plus
vite je pourrais dire le musée cool
c'est moi et pourtant Jacques Charles Le
maître de la revue débaucher du Casino
de Paris par le nouveau directeur du
Moulin Rouge et bien le père du musical
entre autres c'est lui qui le premier à
imaginer la descente d'un escalier par
les girls
mistinguette ne serait pas mistinguette
sans Jacques Charles et guesmar le
dessinateur de costumes et assistant de
la grande dame il pensait pas à ne pas
dépenser si on pouvait dépenser encore
plus il l'aurait fait qui ne connaît pas
la revue mistinguette Montmartre ou bien
évidemment ça c'est pareil
si j'étais pas comme ça
sans mistinguette la maison février
n'aurait jamais vu le jour c'est primacé
a ouvert ses portes il y a tout juste 90
ans
[Musique]
et a récemment été racheté par le Moulin
Rouge des plumes pour certaines
protégées comme les graisses le péché
mignon de Mistinguette a été la première
cliente de la maison février on a une
facture qui atteste c'est
ultra prestigieux quoi c'est la star
l'une des premières stars au monde et
c'est la première facture c'est
incroyable
elle a repris le toute cette
effervescence tout symbole de la plume
et hop la billet elle a sublimé pour
pour le spectacle du Moulin Rouge
bonjour la star d'aujourd'hui la meneuse
nationale Mathilde vient respirer la
légèreté de l'atelier il faut dire que
c'est précieux de pouvoir avoir accès
aux plus belles plumes du monde pour le
moulin on est toujours sur les plus
beaux gras de deux autruche de qualité
[Applaudissements]
garde-moi très très joli je vais tomber
amoureux
je suis peut-être déjà tu me fais des
plumes comme ça
[Musique]
redescendons les plumes sur terre
Mathilde doit essayer sa nouvelle
armature pour le grand final du
spectacle
[Musique]
donc c'est la toute nouvelle structure
elle est beaucoup plus haute oui
effectivement
par terre et du coup qui se raccrochait
au talon et dans les escaliers c'est un
peu compliqué mais là du coup c'est
nickel le volume est sympa
voilà et là particularité c'est que
c'est un on pourrait réagir à la lumière
noire donc ça devient fluo il y a toute
une magie sur le final il y a comme
moulin on a cette qualité de Boa qu'on a
ce travail là aussi pointu il y a
l'esthétique mais aussi la force
physique tout se joue aussi avec
l'élastique de derrière c'est
pas là
on peut pas l'avoir avec autre chose
quand même
c'est belle on décidément un quotidien
extraordinaire
[Musique]
les plumes la revue le rêve c'est ce que
la famille Clerico va faire revivre dans
les années 60
une famille italienne qui vient de faire
fortune dans la verrerie et qui achète
le Lido puis le Moulin Rouge
confie la direction alors jeune fils
Jacky qui s'est fait un peu la main au
Lido il lance une première revue
d'envergure cancan en 1972 puis foufou
son succès en 1963 entraîne une
superstition familiale F comme foufou
frisson fascination fantastique festival
follement frénésie
mais l'histoire du f c'est parce que par
pur hasard la première vue s'appelait
froufrou et ça a été un succès inattendu
il se sont dit bah la prochaine on
l'appelle encore un S et puis elle a eu
un succès il a donc la troisième et puis
la quatrième et donc depuis toutes les
revues elle s'appelle avec un F et la
prochaine quand elle sera là elle
s'appelera aussi avec Alex
des années 60 jusqu'aux années 90 aux
commandes un duo du tonnerre il
s'appelle Ruggero Angeletti et Doris
walk ce sont les inséparables
chorégraphes et directeurs artistiques
du Moulin Rouge
était une femme extrêmement belle elle
était grande laver des très belles
jambes il a commencé à danser dans de
petits musicols de Montmartre et puis
elle a commencé à avoir une petite
troupe de danseuses le spectacle les
chorégraphies et les avait dans sa tête
une recette qui marche avec le duo
Ruggero et Doris Jacky le boss Giorgio
veccia et Corrado colabucci les
créateurs des costumes ces costumes s'y
extravagants glamour généreux gourmand
et sensuel si propre au cabaret et qui
continue de faire la grandeur du Moulin
Rouge et les Kirikou ont une idée
géniale de faire venir Joséphine Baker
Joséphine Baker alors Joséphine
extraordinaire magnifique elle
elle adoré les costumes elle disait
toujours moi je veux bien souffrir mais
elle disait quand je rentre sur scène je
vais être très très belle donc je
supporte tout elle supportait tout la
seule chose qu'elle demande qu'elle
exigeait dans toutes ses robes elle
voulait une ceinture ah c'était une
grande ou encore Lisette Malidor meneuse
de revue Moulin Rouge dans les années 70
pour qu'il Gainsbourg a composé des
chansons des tableaux exotiques et
orientaux très appréciés du public et
les offres américains les Cubains ont
toujours fait partie des millions de
Moulin Rouge et là toujours existait
l'exotisme ça veut dire dépendre ce que
dans ce spectacles Moulin Rouge il a
toujours des gens de couleur depuis
l'époque de Joséphine Baker et en plus
et après il a eu des menaces de revues
on a peur de dire bon les Moulin Rouge a
l'impression de la France c'est la
blondeur mais non n'ayez pas peur venez
ils aiment bien ici les métissages et en
fait il cherche très souvent des choses
des personnes uniques des looks uniques
de l'amour des femmes toujours des
femmes de femmes femmes mes femmes
jusqu'au bout des seins ayant réussi
l'amalgame de l'autorité et du charme
[Musique]
rien n'est trop facile pour le Moulin
Rouge qui fait rêver les petites
princesses comme les grandes Rennes
[Musique]
dans cette salle mythique qui respire le
parfum de nostalgie on y va pour nous
c'est très calme boire et rêver rentrer
malheureux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
strictement interdit de photographier ou
de filmer pendant le spectacle
[Applaudissements]
nous protéger jusqu'au matin personne
n'est quand je regarde les
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on y va aussi et on oublie pour voir ces
femmes fier d'affirmer leur féminité
leur beauté leur sens surdité des corps
des parures des plumes des paillettes
des créatures des guerrières têtes
brûlées sur terre
[Musique]
entre en vol et ancrage d'affranchir et
sont devenues précieuses exotiques
élégantes énoncée des beautés
sculpturales belles au Moulin Rouge
bonsoir nous vous souhaitons une belle
soirée et c'était belle au Moulin Rouge
[Musique]